قالت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ان وزير
الخارجيه انتوني بلينكن اقر صفقه محتمله
لبيع بنادق ام 107 عيار
155 مليمترا والمعدات المرتبطه بها
لاسرائيل مقابل
157 مليون ونصف المليون دولار واضاف
البنتاجون ان بلينكن حدد ان هناك حاله
طوارئ تستلزم بيع هذه الاسلحه على الفور
لاسرائيل ما يعلق شرط مراجعه الكونغرس
للصفقه وفي نص اختاره للكونجرس قال بلينكن
انه بالنظر للمصالح القوميه للولايات
المتحده وبموجب التزامها بامن اسرائيل وما
تتعرض له من تهديدات فان هناك حاله طوارئ
تتطلب البيع الفوريه للمواد والخدمات
الدفاعيه لحكومه اسرائيل والتنازل عن
متطلبات مراجعه الكونغرس بهذا الشان واضاف
بلينكن ان اسرائيل ستستخدم هذه الاسلحه
لتعزيز دفاعاتها وردع التهديدات الاقليميه
وهذه هي المره الثانيه التي يتخذ فيها
بلينكن قرارا من هذا النوع متجاوزا
متطلبات مراجعه الكونجرس للمبيعات
العسكريه الاجنبيه منذ بدايه الحرب
الاسرائيليه على قطاع
غزه